everyone has different tastes in movies
but now and then a film comes along that
just defies understanding no matter
which way you slice it whether it's a
high concept art film or just the
product of a ridiculous plot these
movies stick around for one reason they
leave us more confused than ever when
the credits finally roll spoilers coming
up Inland Empire David Lynch's 2006 film
Inland Empire is an insane sort of beast
a three-hour nightmare of a movie
featuring hollywood street prostitutes
and a super weird sitcom about rabbits
it makes Mulholland Drive look like an
episode of Friends it's also as close as
Lynch has ever come to making a full-on
horror movie providing scares more
startling and perplexing than he's ever
dared before but what does it actually
mean
according to the Guardian it's about
whatever you come away thinking it's
about so looks like you got this one
right the prestige Christopher Nolan's
movie about dueling magicians is pure
cinematic sleight of hand a mystery that
keeps all its clues hidden in plain
sight
still there's one aspect of the movie
the ending that continues to leave
viewers confused the ending shows the
length and sheer will go for his magic
when Christian fails Borden discovers a
McCobb storeroom of Angier Zone dead
duplicated bodies still in the boxes
where they drown during each performance
but who is the real consciousness and
the real Angie er it's a brain twister
but Tesla revealed the answer before the
final act of the movie when they
discover the field of cloned hats don't
forget you a hunt which one is mine oh
yeah all of the Angiers are the real
Angie er exact copies who share the
exact same memories motivations and a
fear of death over and over again he
dies for applause always leaving behind
a living copy of himself who's doomed to
drown screaming in a box the following
show having a twin would have been so
much easier under the skin this alien
abduction movie is unlike any other in
the sci-fi genre it's truly only an
abduction movie for the first half after
which the alien played by Scarlett
Johansson
becomes disillusioned with luring humans
into traps when she decides to let one
victim go free the alien goes rogue
curious about this planet its people and
her role as an alien in disguise the
second half of the movie follows the
alien trying to grapple with a growing
sense of her own humanity and the
vulnerability that comes with it
her journey is cut short when a
lumberjack tries to rape her in the
woods
but when Johansson's human skin starts
coming off the attacker burns her alive
look past the sci-fi aspects and this is
essentially the story of a young woman
self-discovery and her devastating fatal
realization that the human world is
harsh unfair and full of Horrors
Jerry Gus Van Sant's Jerry is basically
a movie about nothing it's about two
guys named Jerry who get lost hiking in
the desert they wander around the
endless landscape blaming each other for
their screw-ups until when Jerry kills
the other Jerry and gets out of the
desert it's try stuff and in the end the
movie doesn't do anything but that's
really the point of it the two
protagonists could be anyone and the
journey could be anywhere in this way
Jerry is sort of a universal story
serving as a mirror for viewers
reflecting the petty conflicts and the
damage we do to each other in ourselves
and finally yes
the overwhelming boredom of life filth
starring James McAvoy as corrupt cop
Bruce Robertson filth starts off as a
comedy and murder mystery then steadily
veers off course into a film about
psychological torment the tonal shift is
so dramatic that it's no surprise
viewers can end up losing track of the
plot particularly during the last act
reveal that Bruce has been spending his
nights roaming the streets dressed as
his own estranged wife while on one of
his cross-dressed jeonse he witnessed
the murder he's supposed to solve a fact
he can't reveal without incriminating
himself in the final moments of the film
even though Robertson has a shot at
redemption he chooses not to fix
anything and hangs himself
it's the ultimate kiss off from a
selfish self-preserving man Eraserhead
David Lynch's bizarre first feature film
is a little easier to comprehend than
his reputation suggests at its core it's
a story about the terror of being
new parents from the opening scene to
that monster baby - Perry's visions of
the baby taking his place it all goes
back to the nightmare of fatherhood or
at least that's how most people look at
it
Lynch himself has said the movie is open
to interpretation saying that no one to
my knowledge has ever seen the film the
way I see it which is exactly the point
sometimes in movies it's not about plot
logic it's all about how it makes you
feel can I borrow a feeling thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]